all right christina
christina uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
born in lancaster um raised back and
forth between south central l.a
and uh palmdo how was your childhood
for the most part it was good you had
both your parents
[Music]
somewhat they weren't together but
it was for the majority of my first
beginning of my life i
was told that i had one fat this guy was
my father and
he left then never knew who he was up
until age 15
when they found him but then i s
nothing there was no physical praise
nothing
he was not my father and me my other
sister had the same father so
he went he was already in my life the
whole time
well technically yeah he was any any
abuse in your childhood anything like
that
um just not well it started off normal
you know
sibling fights you know kid kid
master said me my mom sisters everybody
was fighting
but it was good times too
but the abuse turned
different when i was 11. what happened
to love
my mother allowed a drug dealer to rape
me for
dope i'm sorry no
so your mom was an addict yeah she was
um on and off a mess for 30 years
i've been on and off for well i've been
on now since i was 17.
and she allowed her dealer to uh yeah
do you feel like that's changed the
direction of your life
somewhat most people think it's
like oh that's why you're trans not at
all i was like
before that you were i was i always knew
i was
but i didn't come out till i was 15. no
yeah fifteen five fourteen and a half
fifteen how old do you know
23 23. then you've been down here in
skid row for how long
well i don't actually like i'm
technically homeless i don't have my own
place but
i have a lot of like my street family
that i've known for
years so i have like that i have sros
i've been all around here so i've stayed
i was staying with my sister down
you call them your street family no
actually well i tell people that
so they understand like that's not my
blood family but that's my family
you know my i
they're my family just as my as if we
were blood related
so you know that's that's my family so
you have friends
friends but that's i don't consider my
friends that's my family
you know um i stayed with my sister
moving down the street on some domain
with her sro
about two months um
right now i'll go at his right here at
the ford
um monty lives right here at the london
so
you know like right here and when i'm
not staying with them or whatever
you know it's not um
physically possible i'm normally hustle
costume so i can uh pay for
rooms but then again i have to go and
have my uncle
get my room for me for one of my other
members
how do you support yourself well
i haven't seen stuff um
um yeah but
um i'm going i'm trying to get my
uh escalating life permit which i i just
found out about
and didn't know it was illegal what it
is so that way
when i have three plus do whatever i
just have to play them there's a license
for it
i'm a pr i have a permit for escorting i
don't sell sex
and so i i get paid for my time and
companionship that's it that's
interesting
what do you think that's all it is
escorts are not supposed to
have sex they're not supposed to be well
paid for sex
the payment is only for time
apprenticeships they go to
like family up like this you know like
like that's what i mean that's worth
places
um sometimes sex does get involved but
that
you know it's a um controversial
the controversy or something um
but i currently just recently got my
very first job so
um i work at west coast beauty hub um
which is actually owned
by um she's not she's trans and she's
we're actually we're like became friends
but that's also my employer so
you know sometimes we you know we get
too
comfortable if i had so i i remind him
like you know i might
yes you know we're friends we're like
you know we call you closest and stuff
but then they they're still my employer
so you know
we have to learn how to you know manage
and separate those two
you know employ employer and employee
right
and separate that from you know cis and
friend
friendship whatever that's a wise move
uh
are drugs part of your life very myself
which one
math math that's my way but who doesn't
and what does meth do for you
i don't know majority time it's just to
stay up
i don't want to dream i don't want to
sleep until i sleep but i
think when i think i think about too
much and i think about [ __ ] negatively
and then it goes other places but um
i learned to kind of cope with it but
now it's mostly
just to stay up at night for when i go
and prostitute
i go home make more money
but not just amazing and then it turned
eventually wasn't built up into an
addiction
because for the longest when i got like
when i got a juvenile hall i
always said i was like i only want to
hit the uncle i'll [ __ ] around
so you were in juvenile hall as a kid
yeah but what kind of trouble you
what kind of what kind of trouble were
you in um i saw what a deadly weapon
and criminal stance on the police
officer i saw
i saw run away i saw it run away
that's awesome anyways and you're
running away from
placements father own placements
camp your mom lost you at what age
uh she lost my first time at eight
that's what she lost dinner out of that
she lost all of us all eight of us i'm
the youngest out of eight kids
um so when i was eight years old
she we all got taken away me and my
brother
in a classroom together well at that
time it was only
six of us left because there's
one got adopted and the other two
they're already adults so they're
already on their own
but they still live there but the rest
of us were still minor shows
me my brother my sisters and then my
other sister was living with
um my grandmother at the time when she
was still alive
and it showed up so me and my brother
and my sisters to my sisters were
they were in a foster home together the
same one me and my brother weren't the
same one together so
then i got taken away again when i was
13
because my mom's on drugs um
and yeah i remember that very well
yeah i was like yeah you guys are not
taking me i'm not going nowhere i'm not
no nothing i started this once before so
i ran and myself i haven't
right across the middle street ran to a
desert i was in honda at the
and my social wrecker was chasing me in
heels
and they at that time i was it was
before
my transition so i hadn't transitioned
yet so they were still calling me by my
real name which is kevin so
what was the best time of your life
to be honest throughout my life and at
this point i've that was so much but the
things i can't even
i can't even remember
what was the worst time of your life
i don't know i've had so many most
people say would think it would be me
going to prison but
actually it's not actually i would say
president was actually pretty good
experience i wouldn't go back
because if i didn't go to prison i
wouldn't be
able to humble myself as i do today
because before if somebody had called me
a [ __ ] or punk or a [ __ ]
i would just start i was i was we're
fighting
side [ __ ] you're lucky
but it just recently came
it just comes to a point where my
[ __ ] day just keeps you like try me
i don't know if they think it's because
i'm nice i'm at heart i'm running a nice
person
or if they think i'm just because of my
high leg i look like slow and saying
little sweet wipe
like you know so i have to live life
don't let my kindness don't take my kind
of tremendous and don't just look for
you i will still [ __ ] you up
i can i'm still an [ __ ]
but i try not to be but people push my
hand and
then i have to get a smart mouth and my
hands have to get
so in my hand like talk back pretty much
but
i'm trying my hardest to bring from that
i'm not trying to go back further
so um this time you spent
living like this on the streets using
drugs all that
how do you think you've changed because
of is that how i think i've changed
yeah being in this environment
um i've changed a lot
it's humbled me it has
hardened me um
you get streetwise i know that
well i was already savvia from a very
young age
trying to follow my brother and sister
running to the streets
um i used to go into little things
called missions where
who would um my brother and sister would
both have a bike
i'd be on the pigs if one of them and
we'll we'll drive down one of the little
dark streets whatever
and we will steal people's bikes off the
porch and if we're gonna take apart or
whatever some
either sell parts or sell bikes and make
bikes and
then you name it you still talk with
your family
yeah i try to talk to my mom most um
most often now because her health isn't
so good
but i've came to i've not forgiven her
finally but
it's like a long time i barely just
forget we're like
right about three years ago or within
the last three years
what are you worried about
too much
what kind of things
do you worry about i'm going back to
jail
um
my mother's house my sister's house now
because
i she was i just i was just now told
that she has
uh cystic fibrosis and
she also has um type of cancer i don't
know what kind and i'd
rather not know because it would really
bother me um
and she's also pregnancy right now so i
should do anytime
she just has to get dilated the same uh
10 whatever it's called
so what's your biggest regret huh what's
your biggest regret
i don't regret anything i have no
regrets
i want to go back and change anything
i want to be who i am today
if i did so i don't remember anything i
do
anything i've done i don't regret people
hurt because i mean it's all a life
learning lesson so
we learn from what you do
all right christina thank you so much
for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck out there
thank you thank you
you